Let's go next to Montrouge from Chicago.
Did I get that name right?
Yeah, you got that name right.
Good job on it.
And I just want to say I love the show and
been I've been a member and very excited to
thank you.
I get to ask your question, so I just ask
you a quick two part question.
So the first is, what kind of pressure can
leftist and progressive expect to have over
the policy policy agenda of a Biden administration?
If we I don't think it's going to happen.
But let's say we get the 50 senators and we
get the two in Georgia.
If that does happen, what kind of, I guess,
influence we can exert on that?
And then don't just follow up to that with
Florida and especially you go on the fifteen
dollars minimum wage law that passed through
a direct ballot initiative.
Do you see that as a winning strategy to push
for those kind of initiatives?
Well, so there's a couple different things
there.
Let's first talk about the pressure that that
Democrats could put on Joe Biden.
If Democrats take the Senate because Democrats
get the two seats in Georgia, it will be 50
50, meaning Democrats, meaning Joe Biden,
anything he wants to get done, he will likely
need every single Democratic senator.
Now, if you lose one like Joe Manchin as we
talk about, then you'll need a Republican
senator.
So the point is, Joe Biden, if he has a 50
50 Senate with Comilla as the tie breaking
vote, he can't afford to lose a single Democrat
to get big things done, meaning that is the
leverage that the more progressive Democrats
in the Senate can say, you need every single
one of our votes to do a you've got to work
with us on B, that's the leverage that that
leverage doesn't exist if Democrats don't
win the two Georgia Senate races.
So is that part is that part clear?
Yeah.
And, you know, I think I always saw it the
other way, whether Joe Manchin does have the
leverage to pull their votes.
But I guess I didn't realize that, hey, you
know, progressive senators, you know, that
Liz Warren's and whatnot, they have that same
leverage anybody could.
Exactly.
Now, in terms of direct ballot initiatives,
I love direct ballot initiatives, but direct
ballot initiatives happen at the municipal
and state level.
So it's we're talking about different things
altogether.
The direct ballot initiative is not going
to be a replacement to the House and Senate
passing something and it being signed into
law by Joe Biden.
In most cases, there are things you could
say, listen, if you do these in all 50 states,
the effect will be just as if Joe Biden got
it done through the House and Senate.
But in practice, I can't think of anything
that would get through all 50 states.
So so it's just it's a different tool for
different projects.
OK, yeah, now that's a very good explanation
for it, and you have to just love your children.
Yeah, doing great work.
So how cold is it in Chicago these days?
You know, it's not too bad.
It's not too bad.
I guess not.
My gauge of it is how much my dog likes to
be outside.
And right now he hasn't eaten a let's just
say I'm sick of the walk before he is gone.
Yeah.
I mean, even even here in New York City, we've
had some close to close to 60 degree days.
So it's it's quite a scene.
All right, my friend, I appreciate the call.
I mean, it's probably bad.
It probably relates to climate change, but
it's certainly pleasant.
If if nothing else,